comme tous les enfants qui vivent dans
des camps de réfugiés si je ne sais rien
joue dans l'eau sans se méfier sans
savoir que ces ruisseaux sont des égouts
à ciel ouvert
enfant impossible pour elle de les
surveiller en tout temps elle les
avertit de ne pas boire l'eau du puits
la salle de bain etc débarque dans sur
la terre à l'air libre et vont se
mélanger avec l'eau de l'eau potable
l'eau des fleuves l'eau des rivières le
petit pays accueille un million et demi
de réfugiés syriens c'est plus de 30 %
de la population libanaise le choléra
qu'on n'avait pas vu au Liban depuis 30
ans a refait surface dans ses camps qui
sont situés dans la région de beca
considéré comme le grenier du Liban la
plupart des légumes du Liban proviennent
vous accueillez les légumes s'ils sont
approuvés avec l'eau du Canada peuvent
transmettre le choléra aussi sur mal
lavés donc c'est pour ça qu'il y a une
panique un peu au niveau de la
distribution du réseau d'eau
ce qui inquiète le pédiatre c'est que
les enfants libanais non plus l'immunité
pour résister aux maladies infectieuses
la crise économique a des effets
catastrophiques sur leur santé les gens
n'ont plus les moyens de de d'assurer
une solution correcte on est à peu près
80% des enfants libanais qui sont animés
on est en train de commencer à voir des
cas de tétanos parce que les gens
d'abord il n'y a plus beaucoup de
vaccins sur le marché libanais alors
qu'avant la crise on était à la 24e
place mondiale en termes de vaccination
de nos enfants là on est à la 140e place
en Haïti on est encore loin du bilan de
la dernière épidémie de choléra qui
avait fait 10 000 morts mais la
propagation est rapide plus de 2015
était enregistrées en moins d'un mois 8
départements sur 10 sont touchés et la
moitié des malades sont des enfants de
moins de 12 ans s'élève une navette
[Musique]
obligé
dans la région de Port-au-Prince les
violences forcent les habitants à rester
chez eux tout est fermé et ils n'ont pas
accès à de l'eau potable Médecin sans
Frontières s'inquiète d'une propagation
massive l'enquête de la surtout parce
qu'il y a toujours des grosses
difficultés d'approvisionnement à de
l'eau potable pour la population alors
que aussi la Société nationale de l'eau
à connaître depuis pas mal de jours
aussi des problèmes dans la coloration
de l'eau
en Haïti comme au Liban les pannes
d'électricité empêchent les usines
d'assainissement des eaux de fonctionner
normalement
quand elles ne sont pas carrément
inondées comme ce fut le cas cette année
dans de nombreux pays en Asie et en
Afrique
d'une ampleur sans précédent provoque la
plus importante épidémique choléra des
dernières années 33 des 36 états du pays
ont reçu des pluies diluviennes qui ont
fait des dizaines de milliers de 100
abris plus de 10 000 cas de choléra ont
été répertoriés depuis septembre et la
bactérie a tué près de 300 personnes un
bilan très préliminaire quand on a une
population qui est vulnérable
fragilisée qui côtoie le brillon-coléra
mais il l'attrape parce que
contrairement d'habitude elles n'ont pas
accès à de l'eau potable
mais l'accélération des événements
climatiques ouragan feu de forêt
sécheresse et inondations ne provoque
pas d'épidémie dans les pays riches les
changements climatiques ont des effets
dévastateurs sur des populations
appauvries par des conflits et des
crises
par rapport à l'accélération des
différentes épidémies
et si on regarde depuis le début du 21e
siècle il y a cette accélération là se
voit son passe du SAS ou à échanen ou
après ça à l'ébola le Zika les bolas
encore présentement la covid-19 et la
variation simienne c'est qu'on se rend
compte que ça se répète et avec un laps
de temps raccourci selon la pédiatre et
bien d'autres scientifiques la source
principale de cet accélération des
épidémies sera la pression sur
l'environnement la coupe des forêts la
pollution des rivières cette pression
augmente la transmission des virus de
l'animal à l'humain